in the category of screenplays based on
material from another medium the
nominees are all the President's Men
screenplay by William Goldman found for
glory screenplay by Robert gazelle
fellini's Casanova screenplay by
Federico Fellini and Vettel oneis as a
pony the 7% solution
Nicholas Meyer and voyage of the Damned
by Steve shaken and David Butler and the
winner is all the President's Men by
William Golding
I had all kinds of cute humble things to
say and they're all gone
somebody ought to mention Gordon Willis
who did an extraordinary job as
cinematographer I really do believe the
acting level of the movie all the way
through for a large cast was remarkable
and that's the work of Alan Pakula and
finally this movie has been from the
very beginning the obsession of Robert
Redford thank you
excuse me
in the world of motion pictures few
people who are not directly involved
understand the subtlety and the
relevance of those persons responsible
for the quality the actual film stock
and that is the untouched celluloid upon
which is and which are born great works
of art it is for this very reason it's
my hair okay sorry that in the past no
award has yet been given to the men
themselves will actually produce this
bare untouched element upon which we
make the films you so much enjoy you at
home this year once again no award will
be given to its unusual and very strange
category thank